good morning John I'm in Los Angeles
it's got a keeper right at the fork here
kids do not vlog and drive it's not safe
I'm on my way to see one of my very
favorite youtubers in the world at first
John it wouldn't be Los Angeles if it
wasn't stuck in traffic so I'm gonna be
that for a little while just to have the
experience sometimes you get going to
rig a clip and then there's a sea of
brake lights ahead who are all these
people my town does not contain as many
people as this road and fair though what
are you doing this situation okay I
guess you just go to be fair though my
town does not contain a lot of people in
fact I just thought of this statistic
during VidCon last year the Anaheim
Convention Center contained more than a
tenth of my town's population that's
weird according to the tiny person in my
phone I have arrived at my destination
to see Hannah Hart oh this is my project
that I do to deal with despair oh yeah
you speak Japanese huh so tell me I have
beautiful eyes and I thought no Meah wa
totemo cute
thank you that's my target size yes it's
perfect size for you it's true and would
you believe it I'm back in a car again
what a shock this time going to see
believe it they sure what's the most
common annoying question people asked
you what is Nathan Fillion smell like I
get that a lot what does Hank green
smell like you know like the surface of
a tic-tac so yeah no big deal just
hanging out with her she had a lot of
good conversations mean Felicia and me
and Hannah and the other people that
were at that lunch what people man
working in this business it's great to
have them around going to see the fine
brothers right now I have dinner with
them and be in an episode or maybe more
of youtubers react tell me what you
think about YouTube on what regard and
the makers out there all you need is a
flashlight from a flashlight app on your
iPhone to give you wonderful light no
matter where you are
benny and rafi find the creators of my
music
people react to things Joe we're the
second coolest brother team no neither
of us are as cool okay back in the
Chrysler again I'm back in the Chrysler
again why don't I start that any key
that I can't sing him to go back to the
hotel where I'm gonna end this video and
then I'm gonna go to sleep and then I'm
gonna get up tomorrow dime that I do a
very similar thing tomorrow because
that's why I'm in LA most online video
people live in LA I don't like living in
LA because they don't like to drive and
as you have seen today that's mostly
what you do when you live in Los Angeles
John I just want to say thank you for
getting me involved in this crazy
business in the first place I'm so
thankful that there are all these great
people that I can talk to about online
video and who think intelligent and
interesting thoughts about it so thanks
to Hannah and Felicia and the fine
brothers and all the other people that I
chatted with the day and John I'll see
you on Tuesday